[Music]
thank you
this is a special edition of Sky News
that turned live from gaziento in Turkey
more than 20 000 people have died
following the earthquakes as people here
start to bury the dead
the first aid lorries finally start to
reach Syria and some of the more remote
areas of Turkey
and we witness the pain and despair of
people waiting to hear if their loved
ones have made it out alive
also ahead tonight nearly two weeks
after Nicola bully disappeared the
search for the missing mum moves out to
sea
more than 7 million people wait for
elective surgery with strikes adding to
the pressures on the NHS and more plans
for tomorrow
we have now realized that winter
pressures are 12 months not just three
months
the Church of England shifts its stance
meaning priests will be permitted to
bless same-sex civil marriages
[Music]
the composer behind hits including Walk
On By and say a little prayer dies at
the age of 94. and wondering and we'll
take a first look at tomorrow's front
pages in our press preview from around
10 40.
foreign
turkey and still rescue workers are
desperately searching for any signs of
survival but today came the news that
more than 20 000 people have died since
the earthquake hit on Monday there are
still pockets of Hope here and today
news that the first Vans carrying Aid
across the border into Syria since the
earthquake struck
the first earthquake of 7.8 magnitude
came in the early hours of Monday
morning the red area on this map shows
the areas that experienced the worst
affected regions It Was Then followed by
an Aftershock of 7.5 magnitude just
hours later to the north the World
Health Organization estimates that more
than 23 million people have been
affected across turkey and Syria more
than a million of whom are children
Syrian State media said more than 298
000 people have been displaced in the
government-controlled parts of the
country but that doesn't include Rebel
held idlib now Sky News teams have
reached the earthquakes epicenter in
caraman marash as well as the Syrian
border where survivors are still waiting
for Aid and later in the program we'll
be looking at how these earthquakes
cause so much destruction reducing
high-rise buildings to Rubble but first
our Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
reports from the city of adiaman
[Music]
turkey is burying its dead
loved ones crushed while they slept
children parents partners
the loss is profound
This Woman's daughter is among those
killed
when her body was found she had her baby
in her arms the pain is too much
I wish I died and my children had lived
she says
[Music]
grief Echoes around adiaman
the earthquake totaled much of the city
but people say it took two days for help
to arrive
by which time the voices below the
rubble had fallen silent
so the body bags keep arriving
50 here in an hour
and with them the anger mounts
foreign
curses the president she says she hears
her nephew begging for help from the
wreckage help that never came
others are still waiting for news
when this apartment collapsed Holmes
became tombs
as Rescuers search for The Hundreds
still missing
distraught relatives watch on
the only thing we have is hope the mood
tells me so we wait to the end
six of his family are buried here he has
little else to lose
whole families died in this collapse
Generations wiped out and this is a
pattern which is repeated tens of times
in this city
thousands of times across turkey
[Music]
for now they will mourn their dead
but with each new coffin the same
question
if help had come sooner
could this life have been saved
Siobhan Robbins Sky News adiaman turkey
[Music]
well it's approaching four days since
the earthquake struck in the early hours
of Monday morning and the so-called
golden period when survivors may still
be found alive is coming to an end but
we have witnessed moments when people
are lifted from the rubble our
International correspondent John Sparks
has the latest from caraman marash at
the epicenter of the earthquake and a
warning his report contains pictures of
bodies being removed from the scene of
the disaster
the air is soaked in dust and smoke
the city marked with concrete Mounds
but in this apocalyptic State there is
evidence of life
human beings still breathing in the
rubble
apra apartment block we saw an Israeli
Rescue Team exploring the remains
one of the first International groups to
reach caraman Mirage
and they had made a life-saving
discovery
a young woman had been rescued from the
Gloom her name zayap chivi
she was fast asleep when the earthquake
struck dressed in polka dot pajamas and
we could see her shivering and crying
after her three-day ordeal
we're here we're here don't be afraid
said a paramedic
her younger sister Ellis followed right
behind the 20 year old was also
shivering
[Music]
but The Rescuers were elated and the
family Overjoyed praying for a miracle
they'd been delivered to thank you very
much thank you very much
name is Burak and he told us he's the
girl's cousin
think that you had lost her or did you
still have hope in your heart we thought
they were dead we prepared the burial
plot
the Israelis said the sister's survival
owed much to Chance some information
from an earlier success
we pulled out a man named Hussein he was
65 years old
and he told us that he heard voices
and we penetrated the additional room
and we didn't find anyone
but we decided to return to this
building again
maybe he was right
so it was not so close but we found two
women here
we've just come around the corner it's
the same building but the contrast could
not be any greater these are local
people they are using
crowbars and Spades
to try and get access to the building
they want to do the same thing they're
trying to to save people's lives they're
trying to retrieve bodies but it is
going to take them much much longer to
do it
I'll be they can smell and in some cases
see the bodies but it doesn't mean they
can get them out what is happening here
we can smell a body here says this
volunteer the body is lying on a bed so
we're trying to dislodge it
victims make an undignified trip to a
sports stadium for identification
some go by hand
others in diggers
while the injured go to local hospitals
like this one which has turned its
reception into a giant Ward
here we met a relative of zayap and elif
and we asked him how they were doing
normal no injuries said cousin qasim
chivett but they're bruised and cold and
they're trying to revive them
Specialists and supplies have begun to
arrive here but they can't meet the
demand in this traumatized City
John Sparks Sky News in caraman marash
well in Syria residents there have
already endured years of war and now
they are waiting days for help and much
needed Aid today though the first aid
supplies have finally crossed the border
into Syria and now many syrians who fled
our returning home to help yusra Elber
gear reports from the Syria turkey
border
Volunteers in idlib are doing what they
can with what they have
cut off from the world and International
Rescue efforts
this man begs the International
Community to help with a breaking voice
some of those who responded to us
yesterday are dead today
this site is just one of many in a
war-torn country further flattened by
these earthquakes
this volunteer says there are around 500
families buried under this Rubble women
and children they don't know who is dead
and who is alive
blankets are used as body bags and this
small bundle carried out of the wreckage
tells the story of a tragic end to a
short life
but there are still Miracles at play
the newborn baby pulled out from under
collapsed building still attached to her
mother now has a name the doctors have
called her Aya it alludes to the sign of
a miracle a quranic revelation straight
from God
the first few trucks carrying a to Sarah
finally made it through the bab and HOA
border point
but many say that it's too little too
late
all other Crossings are currently
excluded from the United Nations
cross-border agreement with the assert
regime
this is a border crossing into Northwest
Syria only an hour away from Aleppo over
the last 11 years of war it seemed
Millions pass through into turkey
seeking refuge and now many syrians are
moving back that way into the country to
help with rescue efforts
anxious like these men here anxious to
make it through and help
he tells me he sees no reason why the
world isn't rushing in to support Syria
I ask about the sanctions and they say
they shouldn't be enforced on the people
he points in the direction of turkey and
then back to the Border they're still
finding survivors what about us he says
there's no State there's nothing
as they wait to get in a truck goes back
and forth taking the bodies of syrians
home to be buried and then back into
turkey to retrieve some more
Sky News killis turkey
well when the 7.8 magnitude earthquake
struck in the early hours of Monday
morning many people were in their homes
sleeping those homes sometimes in huge
apartment blocks are now reduced to
Rubble in the coming days and weeks they
will inevitably be questions about how
this amount of death and destruction was
possible Sky Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark has been analyzing the
building data in Turkey
the images are almost unbearably
distressing collapsed buildings which
are the main reason for the catastrophic
loss of life resulting from this
earthquake so why was this one so bad
well the main thing of course was just
how severe the earthquake was this is a
shake map for the first 7.8 magnitude
Quake the red triangles are part of a
sensor Network that measure ground
movement in some locations the speed the
ground mood was extreme here in hajila
ground acceleration for the Quake was
approaching 8 meters per second in
kurikan it was well above seven meters a
second now these measurements are
preliminary but Sky News understands
that in some areas they exceeded levels
expected in turkey's earthquake design
codes buildings are designed to cope
with a one in 475-year earthquake event
and not collapse in a one in two and a
half thousand year event yet the shaking
appears to exceed the upper limit of
what would be expected every two and a
half thousand years
even a very well uh designs and well
executors building would have suffered
would have would have been challenged uh
but again this doesn't rule out that the
building stock that's that we are um
seeing uh basically uh collapsing uh was
free of uh defects and problems
previous earthquakes in Turkey have
highlighted those problems both the age
but also quality of newer building
construction the city of gaziantet
experienced considering less intense
shaking yet buildings still failed
sometimes catastrophically and these
risks were known last year a team of
Turkish seismologists studied the city
of gaziantet using earthquake risk data
they identified which neighborhoods were
most vulnerable to a big Quake those in
the darkest colors in this map where
they forecast 50 to 60 percent of the
buildings to suffer damage generally the
areas with the oldest or poorest quality
buildings but crucially the hypothetical
earthquake they based their study on was
10 times less powerful than the one that
struck on Monday
so age and quality of buildings was a
major factor but so too perhaps was the
estimation of risks and don't forget
this wasn't just one earthquake a huge
magnitude 7.5 Aftershock toppled
buildings that survived the initial
quake and damaged others Beyond repair
even these structures that remain
standing may now be uninhabitable a
colossal challenge for authorities
already dealing with at least tens of
thousands of people made homeless by
this disaster
well this is now thought to the turkey
and Syria's most devastating natural
disaster in over 80 years and the
disasters emergency committee have
released an appeal for help here's some
of that appeal
please donate now
the trauma cannot be undone but we can
and we must help
[Music]
and of course uh the earthquake is being
covered in tomorrow's newspapers the
Metro leads on a photo of a two-year-old
being rescued here in Turkey after
spending 79 hours under the rubble the
press review
we'll preview Raleigh we'll be uh taking
place a little later because of our
especially extended uh News at 10
that'll be at 10 40 uh this evening
well here the rescuing or the rescue
efforts uh go on they're about to remove
a very large piece of masonry as you can
see and we'll be back
a little later in the program
good evening back here it's been nearly
two weeks since The Disappearance of
Nicola bully who went missing while
walking her dog by a river in Saint
Michael's on wire in Lancashire the
police looking for the mother of two
today moved their search to the coast
from there into Mount Rashid reports
searching at Sea almost two weeks on and
for police the choppy coastline is now
the focus as they continue to look for
missing Nicola bully
they're scouring Waters over 10 miles
Downstream from where the mum of two was
last spotted police believe day by day
finding her in the open sea becomes more
of a possibility
at the bench where Nicola's phone dog
Willow and its lead were found searching
has come to a halt investigators
confirmed resources are now being piled
into finding Clues further along this
Deep fast-flowing River if the police's
theory that Nicola bully accidentally
slipped into the river wire is true than
finding any trace of her Downstream will
prove incredibly difficult the tidal
nature of this River will cause almost
anything to move back and forth
constantly and the area to search
including the coast is vast
the size and scale and the expanse of
that area will obviously present
difficulties there are obviously
currents and and tidal uh flaws to
consider uh that could take things in in
various Direction there will be sand
banks you've got hide side Lord side but
all these things will be factored in
with the with other agencies partner
agencies who've got expertise in that
area who will be working with the police
uh to help them formulate the best
possible search parameters for that area
whilst her friends and family have
praised the efforts of the police for
them something doesn't add up they want
all possibilities of her disappearance
investigated
Friday morning marks two weeks since
Nicola left her home dropped off her
children at school and took her dog for
a walk it was nothing out of the
ordinary what was however is she didn't
come home a mystery for many an
agonizing fortnite for a family in Zaman
Rashid Sky News Lancashire
foreign
Crews reached emergencies and now
quicker in January compared with
December but they're still falling short
of targets and pre-pandemic levels
ongoing strikes continue to parl
pressure on the service with more
walkouts expected tomorrow
well a year ago NHS England launched its
elective recovery plan to reduce a
backlog of 6 million people waiting for
routine hospital treatment well that
number is now 7.2 million increasing
every month except January this year the
number has started to stabilize but
there are concerns industrial action is
impacting efforts with more than 137 000
Hospital appointments postponed since
strikes began our health correspondent
Ashish Joshi reports now from
Heatherwood Hospital in ascot any
concerns from anyone that's as you
continue disrupting for surgeon Jeremy
Granville Chapman and his team this
operation is the very definition of
routine we're going to repair the torn
tendon at the front which is one of his
deep layer of muscles called the rotator
cuff they've carried out more than a
thousand joint operations at Heatherwood
Hospital in under 10 months
is patient with the girl slipped in his
garden in August he landed awkwardly
tearing the tendons in his arm before
today he was one of more than seven
million people waiting for routine
Hospital treatments that waiting list
has grown by over a million in the last
year alone and while there's no doubt
that elective surgery hubs like this one
will have an impact
that impact will depend very much on
other factors like the workforce crisis
and the industrial action that's been
staged by health workers
this is a specialist planned care
facility they can do as many as 80 joint
Replacements a week and the hope is that
hospitals like this one will mean less
pressure is felt Across The Wider Health
Service we have now realized that winter
pressures are 12 months not just three
months which means the acute sites are
not going to be able to do planned
activity what they plan for so we got to
create more space is this going to be a
model for the future this is the model
we're already looking can we expand this
unit can we make two more thetas next
year to take the pressure off
the government has made reducing NHS
waiting lists one of its five priorities
for the year
and new surgical hubs like this one
might be the key to making it happen
but it is yet to reveal how it plans to
recruit and retain enough staff
announcement of a long-term Workforce
plan is positive what we need in that
Workforce plan is a plan for both
increasing the workforce how many
Workforce we need how you retain the
workforce and also how we fund all of
these extra staff
pradeep is now out of surgery and should
be home in just a couple of hours you
don't realize I mean how much you take
things for granted um with your mobility
and
being able to move your
you know your arms how much it restricts
you
so yeah I'm glad
elective surgery but also life-changing
with Millions more waiting in line our
shish Josh is Sky News at Heatherwood
hospital and ask us
the latest on the war in Ukraine now and
president zelensky is continuing his
tour of Europe today addressing the
European Parliament in Brussels the
Ukrainian president told assembled
politicians that Russia is trying to
annihilate European values and renewed
his plea for modern jets today a Kremlin
spokesperson told Sky News that talks of
sending NATO jets would lead to an
escalation of tension around this
conflict our International Affairs
editor Dominic waghall reports
on a British jet president zielinski
landed for the second part of his
European mission in Paris first then on
to Brussels
thank you
warm greetings for the wartime president
and a welcome from EU leaders gathered
to hear him
some like the Dutch have already sounded
open to giving him fighter jets others
less so after addressing Britain's MPS
yesterday his Excellency
he was here to Rally support in the
European Parliament
glory to Ukraine
but it was at the press conference
afterwards where he claimed he's already
been given assurances by Europe he will
be sent Jets to help fight the Russians
I have been very inspired by your
statements that Europe will be with us
until our Victory I've heard it from a
number of the European leaders and I'm
very grateful to them for this I've
heard about the Readiness to give us the
necessary weapons and support including
the aircrafts
ukrainians need multi-role combat
aircraft like f-16s made in America but
flown by several European countries and
europhyte is widely used by European Air
Forces too military analysts believe
it's only a matter of time before
warplanes are sent to Ukraine when the
decision was made to send men battle
tanks that was the step change and
having done that I think politically
that's the Allied countries saying we
are going to back you to the point until
you defeat and push the Russians out of
the geographic boundaries of Ukraine
in response Russia released these
pictures today of a tank Factory toured
by a former prime minister
it's clear in this case it's natural for
us to increase the production of various
types of weapons and military equipment
including modern tanks
president zielinski flies home knowing
he has brought Europe closer to upping
the ante again as allies consider
sending warplanes to support tanks
already on their way Dominic wagorn Sky
News
the U.S House of Representatives has
unanimously voted to condemn China's
balloon surveillance program as a Brazen
violation of U.S sovereignty the house
voted
419-0 for the resolution five days after
the U.S Air Force shot down the device
over the Atlantic Ocean beijing's always
maintained that the balloon was
monitoring weather for civilian purposes
former culture secretary Nadine Doris
has announced that she will not stand at
the next general election Ms Doris has
been MP for mid-fed feature since 2005
and in recent years has earned a
reputation as one of the most loyal
supporters of former prime minister
Boris Johnson
the Press Regulators launched our
investigation into Jeremy Clarkson's
article in the sun about the Duchess of
Sussex his column in December received
more than 25 000 complaints and he later
apologized the independent press
standards organization says it'll
examine potential breaches of the code
involving accuracy harassment and
discrimination
the Church of England has voted to
recognize and bless same-sex marriages
and unions however a ban on equal
marriage within the church itself
remains after several days of divisive
debate in the Synod the church's
National Assembly the motion was carried
the skies Shaman Freeman Powell now
reports
a two-day debate in the Anglican
Church's Parliament
is in favor please show
those against
but it's an issue that's been wrangled
over for years we've spent decades even
trying to argue for the church to say
anything positive in a corporate way
about same-sex relationships today was
that day today General Synod said and
affirmed there is good in same-sex
relationships this is part of God's good
creation and for me that's a wonderful
first step for the first time ever the
Church of England says same-sex couples
will be publicly unreservedly and
joyfully welcomed inside of the church
it now means that same-sex couples can
have their ceremonies blessed but they
still won't be able to get married
inside of the church itself
the Church of England is under No
Illusion there are deep Anglican
divisions on the issue not just in this
country but around the world where
consequences can be grave
I'm genuinely torn by this
the differences we have here
are small compared to those
with many around the communion
this isn't just about listening to the
rest of the world it's caring
let's just be clear on that it's about
people who die
women who'll be raped
children who'll be tortured
and a proposal intended to put an end to
Decades of disagreement has instead
exposed deep-rooted disparities a number
of us voted against because we don't
think it's possible to keep everybody
happy you can't say that a certain
pattern relationships is blessed on the
one hand but at the same time say it
doesn't contravene the the current
teaching of the church
although the motion was passed there are
still terms that need to be finalized in
a proposal that's gone too far for some
and not far enough for others Sherman
Freeman Powell Sky News
welcome back to uh gaziantep in Turkey
where the uh uh search and rescue
operations continue behind me here we
have some breaking news by the way on
Aid being sent from the UK the mod has
said that the UK will send thousands of
thermal blankets on RAF transport planes
are departing tonight further emergency
aid issued in the coming days will
include a field hospital with a 24 7
operating theater as well as high
dependency and general Ward patient beds
that help coming in from the UK now
we've been here for a few days and uh
well we've watched these people
frantically searching for their loved
ones under piles of debris uh they've
wets in moments when they realize that
their search is lost and also rare
moments of Joy when The Rescuers reach
uh people alive earlier we traveled to
the city of nurda here in southern
turkey
and this is what we found
suddenly in The Battered town of nerda
there is excitement
they drill their way down together
[Applause]
eventually they see a face
a man named Halle and he's alive
and ambulance is brought closer
blankets and a stretcher are called for
and his cousin and others who know him
dare to Hope
and watching you just thought of The
Bravery of the men working to get him
out working below shattered leaning
buildings that could collapse at any
time
then a doctor calls for water for
Hallett
but it is too late he dies before they
can save him
moments later more shouting and they run
to the back of the building
heard my sister crying in the rubble
please be quick please please
the grandfather is being ushered away
from a scene he can't bear to leave
is she dead he says please be alive
[Music]
with the ambulance on its way the search
team listens for the sign of life
[Music]
we are here since yesterday night he
tells me we will find her we will find
her and with that the sister of the
missing girl Moon passes out awesome
they didn't hear another voice but that
doesn't stop them waiting
as we left Hope was fading here
the girl who fainted was back she will
not give up
an International Rescue Team arrives to
raise hopes again
and so the weight goes on
what we witnessed here is happening
right now across this region the problem
is that time is fast running out
yes it really is the Frantic nature of
the searching going on now but it's the
humanity as well people here and across
this region just willing these Rescuers
to have some success and there is you
know desperate hope but uh that's
followed more often than not by by the
depths of grief